here's what would happen if you were  injected with graphene  graphene is only one atom thick  discovering it has revolutionized  battery and information technology since  it's 100 times stronger than steel and  powerful enough to repel most gases and  liquids if graphene were injected into  your body a small amount could cross the  important blood-brain barrier most of it  would dissolve over the next two days  however the jagged graphene  nanoparticles could pierce your blood  cells and completely disrupt their  functions and if it damaged your kidney  cells proteins could leak into your  urine this would make your eyes and  ankles swell this condition known as  nephrotic syndrome would also kill your  appetite technically you wouldn't die  but one thing is for sure it wouldn't be  a pleasurable experience because